[Music]
have you been waiting on the edge of
your seat for titanfall tues live fire
update well good news you'll be playing
in no time as it launches this week I'm
Matt this is a game spot news update and
make sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
ongoing coverage of free titanfall 2
content developer Respawn Entertainment
has announced that the live fire update
releases on februari 23rd it brings a
mode of the same name which pits two
teams of six against each other in a
series of 60 second rounds in order to
win one of those rounds a team needs to
eliminate the other squad or be holding
the neutral flag when time runs out the
mode is joined by two maps that are
designed specifically for live fire and
were created to push players together
and force confrontation the live fire
update also introduces a new map for the
Coliseum mode in addition to a new pilot
execution and a wide variety of balance
changes they include improvements to the
holographic decoy ability and
adjustments to specific guns and Titans
you can check them all out on gamespot
com but if you want more firepower here
check out our video on the bizarre
aliens and weapons of prey